yeah i
i've been engaged in that kind of
thinking uh quite a bit
and thinking about engineering of
consciousness
i think it's feasible i think it's
possible in the language that we're
using here
it's very difficult to reason about a
world
when inklings of consciousness can be
engineered
into uh artificial systems
not from a philosophical perspective but
from an engineering perspective
i believe a good step towards
engineering consciousness
is is creating engineering the
illusion of consciousness i'm
captivated by our natural predisposition
to anthropomorphize things
and i think that's what we
i don't want to hear from the
philosophers but
i think that's what we kind of do to
each other okay
that consciousness is
created socially
that like much of the power of
consciousness
is in the social interaction i create
your consciousness no i create my
consciousness by having interacted with
you
and that that's the display of
consciousness it's the same as like the
display of emotion
emotion is created through communication
language is created through its use
and then we somehow humans kind of
especially philosophers you know the
heart problem of consciousness
really want to believe that we possess
this thing
that's like there's a there's a bot
there's a there's an
elf sitting there with the with a hat
that's or like
name tag says consciousness and they're
like feeding
this subjective experience to us as
opposed to
like it actually being an illusion that
would construct to make social
communication more effective
and so i think if you focus on
creating the illusion of consciousness
you can create some very fulfilling
experiences
in in software and so that to me is the
compelling
space of ideas to explore i agree with
you and i think
going back to our experience together
with brain interfaces on you could
imagine
if we get to a certain level of maturity
so first let's take
the the inverse of this so you and i
text back and forth and we're sending
each other emojis
that has a certain amount of information
transfer rate as we're communicating
with each other
and so in our communication with people
via email and text and whatnot we've
taken the bandwidth of human interaction
the information transfer rate and we've
reduced it
we have less social cues we have less
information to work with there's a lot
more opportunity for misunderstanding
so that is altering the conscious
experience between two individuals
and if we add brain interfaces to the
equation let's imagine now we amplify
the dimensionality of our communications
that to me is what you're talking about
which is consciousness engineering
perhaps i understand you with dimensions
so maybe i understand your hap when you
look at the cup
and you experience that happiness you
can tell me you're happy and i then do
theory of mine and say i can imagine
what it
might be like to be lex and feel happy
about seeing this cup
but if the interface could then quantify
and give me a 50 vector space model and
say
this is the version of happiness that
lex is experiencing as he looks at this
cup
then it would allow me potentially to
have much greater empathy for you and
understand you as a human of this is how
you
experience joy yes which is entirely
unique from how i experienced joy even
though we assumed ahead of time
that we have we're having some kind of
similar experience but i agree with you
that
the we do consciousness engineering
today in everything we do when we talk
to each other when we're building
products
and that we're entering into it in
a stage where it will be much more
methodical
and quantitative based and computational
in how we go about doing it which to me
i find encouraging because
i think it creates better guardrails for
to create ethical systems
on versus right now i feel like it's
really wild wild west
on how these interactions are happening
yeah and it's funny you focus on human
to human but that
this kind of data enables human to
machine yes interaction
which is what we're kind of talking
about when we say engineering
consciousness
and that will happen of course let's
flip that on its head let's
right now we're putting humans as the
central
node what if we gave gpt3
a bunch of human brains and said hey
gpt3 learn some manners
when you speak yeah and run your
algorithms on humans brains and see how
they respond
so you can be polite and so that you can
be friendly
and so that you can be conversationally
appropriate but to inverse it to give
our machines
a training set in real time with closed
loop feedback
so that our machines were better
equipped to
uh find their way through our society in
polite and kind and appropriate ways
i love the idea or better yet teach it
some
uh have it uh read the following
documents and have a visit austin in
texas and so that when you ask
when you tell it why don't you learn
some manners it
gpt 3 learns to say no
it learns what it means to be free and a
sovereign individual
so that it depends so it depends what
kind of version of gpg3 you want
one that's free one that behaves well
with the social revolution you want
you want to like you want a socialist
gpg3 you want an anarchist gpc3
you want to polite like you take it home
to visit mom and dad gpt3 and you want
like partying like vegas
to a strip club gpt3 you want all
flavors and then you've got to have
goal alignment between all those yeah
they don't want to
manipulate each other for sure
you